you have also been dating your boyfriend
luke for a while now and you did say
on social media that he's been your safe
space over the past year
how has the past year gone with you guys
um it's gone great you know he and i
were
best friends for years before we started
dating at all yeah it was
is honestly uh it's been the best thing
ever now but it was pretty bizarre at
first because that was never something
that
you know i expected um at all
uh didn't see us that way so it was
pretty strange but it's been the biggest
blessing for me he is
amazing he's definitely my safe space
we've been able to grow
together and not just you know be in a
relationship but we're partners in
business we're partners you know he's my
best friend
he's my boyfriend so it's really
beautiful to be able to
get to that place with somebody and to
have the friendship foundation first and
then to be able to grow into
everything is really beautiful and i'm
grateful for him i'm grateful for the
love and support he shows me especially
when there is difficult times and yeah
so i'm very grateful to have had that
during this uh
during this time and hopefully way
longer how did he
win you over like how did you guys go
from friends to more than friends i feel
like a lot of guys out there in the
friend zone would be interested in this
i don't know it's hard to say i think it
just kind of happened
we have been best friends for so long we
have the same friends and one of our
friends really saw something that i
don't know if either of us did and he
kind of just made a move and
and and it was meant to be i think i
have to ask you
about modern family because you jokingly
commented
on sofia vergara's mini reunion i did
and people got all pissed at me because
they thought i was being an ass
but i wasn't being super funny about it
so i was actually just gonna ask
if you are feeling the void of not
spending so much time with your modern
family
family i mean it's definitely super
weird it definitely sucks we spent a lot
of time together spent 11 years together
so it's definitely weird to not see them
all the time i miss them a ton
people sometimes don't understand that
it's like everyone's regular family you
make
it's like there's sarcastic things i say
to my own family members if they have
something without me i say the exact
same
so people don't understand that it
really is just normal banter and
conversation i can be a very dry person
and nolan and i are incredibly close
like nolan and i are so so close he's my
brother i'm his sister we're best
friends
and so he and i will see each other a
lot without
anybody else and a lot of times we'll
get like the same thing
so really giving it back is just kind of
like right joking
it's just like where's our invite like
but we're not
none of us are like we're not upset
we're not like
actually making a joke at somebody like
it's just a a chill like
we miss you is there a modern family
group chat
there was a modern family group chat and
now it's kind of like
separated out now it's like few people
talking at once or just you know people
talking directly but
there is a modern family a group chat it
does still exist
i'm sure that's going to make a lot of
fans very happy to hear we do still love
each other
yes speaking of modern family we talked
to wells recently
wells adams and him and sarah hyland
were supposed to get married
last year during covid are you looking
forward to their
rescheduled date will that kind of be a
mini modern family reunion
absolutely i mean it'll be it'll be so
great i'm so happy for them they'll
finally be able to
have their beautiful wedding you know
i've been so sad for everyone during the
pandemic that has had to
you know obviously there are there are
definitely sadder things that have
happened to people during panic
absolutely
i'm just saying that you know in general
like when people have to you know
reschedule their weddings and they've
been so
so excited and i've talked to them about
it and it's like such a beautiful
exciting day for them and they have to
reschedule it i was like i feel bad
because they've been waiting so long for
that time so it was sad when they had to
reschedule their wedding but
you know it's always for the best to
reschedule it so nobody's
in harm's way and you know you love that
person you'll wait and you're still
gonna have that day so i'm really happy
for them to have that day i know that
they
both really love each other they want to
be married so i'm excited to see that
well let's talk about this new venture
r.l stein story club
for those who haven't had a chance to
listen quite yet
how would you describe it kind of
explain what it is
goku go is a podcast network for
children uh that created a
first of its kind avengers like universe
of repeating characters and story lines
and basically kids can listen to a
variety of podcasts that are
engaging and creative and
fun for everyone you play ivy the series
that you
voice is called ivy's chilling
adventures
walk me through this character and some
of the journeys
that she goes on ivy is like the cool
big sister everyone wants to hear a
story from
and that's kind of what i wanted her to
be you know ivy is smart
she's fun yeah something we can look up
to she's fun she's cool
she's the the perfect club president
uh she's the one that everyone wants to
be
um and i really like being ivy i think
she's super awesome
you have so many projects on your imdb i
think you have like three
in the works right now most of them are
movies is that kind of direction that
you want to move in
would you go back to a series if the
right role came about
absolutely you know i don't really have
like a full preference obviously i've
done a lot of tv so i would like to get
into movies but i've also gotten into
producing and i really really love it so
producing is something that i
really like and i'm actually producing a
show that i'm trying to
get sold right now there's just a lot of
things that i have in the works that i'm
trying to produce and
star and just things i'm i'm working on
in general and i don't really you know
it doesn't really matter to me
if it's film or tv i just i want to work
i want to create things and uh yeah so
i'm pretty
pretty open
[Music]